well the United States has called on
Russia to immediately deescalate
violence in Aleppo in Syria's we've
heard both President Obama and President
Putin are attending a summit in Peru
it's mr. Obama's final stop on his last
world tour as US commander in chief the
two leaders have often endured a
troubled relationship but could that be
about to change when Donald Trump takes
over joining me now is professor of
politics and director of the Jordan
Center for the Advanced Study of Russia
at New York University Joshua Tucker
good evening to you first of all let's
characterized or if you could for us
that the relationship between Russia and
America as it stands now the current
state of russian-american relations is
one of a lot of tension I think is the
most the best way to sort of a appraise
this there has been a lot of pushback
between Russia and the United States
there are a lot of flash points of
contention most notably the Russian
annexation of Crimea and as well as the
Western response to that involving
sanctions and then large differences of
opinion about the best way to proceed in
terms of the Syrian conflict and in your
estimation could president elect Trump
change that the status of this
relationship how do his views perhaps
lean to a more conciliatory relationship
with Russia right so the key word in
your question there jillian is whether
whether president electron could change
the relationship absolutely he could
change the relationship whether he will
is the most important question here and
I think at this point the most important
thing we can communicate to watchers to
people who are interested in the
us-russian relations is just how much
fundamental uncertainty there is at this
point in time there are two things to be
aware hub first of all president like
truck made very conciliatory remarks
very positive remarks towards President
Putin as part of his campaign but it's
important to know that this is one of
them perhaps the most extreme place in
which he dove tailed from sort of
traditional Republican positions on the
US relations on in general but in in
this area of us relations towards Russia
so this is going to be one big question
the second thing is trying to figure out
whether his positive comments about
President Putin were related more to its
president Putin's style leadership and
style of projecting
power in the in the world or as opposed
to sort of belief in the sort of
legitimacy of president Putin's
interests in Europe in the Middle East
and these are two different questions
and as you say I mean he might have
identified elements of president Putin's
character that appealed to him but for
the the mainstay of Republicans they
will be against any sort of a
conciliatory move all or certainly any
appearance that America is a cal
towering to Russia oh absolutely i think
that's totally correct and i also think
you know there's going to be strong as
you said there's going to be tension
between traditional Republican positions
towards Russia and what President Trump
wants to do in terms of Russian
relations if he is looking at sort of a
fundamental reversal of the positions
that the US government is held
previously that being said it's
important to realize that of all the
question marks we have about how
American policy is going to change
following the new administration coming
up our foreign policy is probably the
area where the president has the most
ability to unilaterally influence
changes in policy which makes in
particular interesting the question of
who he is going to choose vertex
Secretary of State Secretary of Defense
you mentioned in the lead in that that
Mitt Romney is potentially being
considered for Secretary of State Mitt
Romney had a very different take on
Russia during his presidential campaign
just four years ago so that would
immediately kind of bring this issue to
the forefront let's talk about NATO and
president elect Trump he's questioned
the existence of NATO and perhaps
America's role or how large a role they
should have it and certainly that that
member states should contribute more
financially that we would imagine would
be music to Putin's is again it depends
it really what the what what you think
the implication of that statement is if
the implication of that statement is
that Trump wants our NATO allies to
contribute a larger portion of their
budget towards military spending that's
actually if that happens is not going to
necessarily be music to president
Putin's ears right if those comments
signify less of a fundamental commitment
to the NATO alliance then I think that
is question that is music to president
Putin's here so it so again it's a very
big question is this Trump approaching
it as a dealmaker who looks at this
situation and says hey the United States
is getting
an advantage of in this deal and we need
our partners to contribute more to
military spending or is Trump looking at
this as saying this is not where my
interests lie my interests lie elsewhere
my foreign policy interests are much
more focused on Isis I'm less concerned
about traditional us concerns in Europe
and it's part of a sort of larger
overall push towards a kind of more
isolationist foreign policy of the
United States but again I want I want to
come back to what I started with Trump
said a lot of things during the campaign
and we just really do not have much of
an idea of what's going to happen next
and he has an awful wide latitude as
president in terms of the policies that
he wants to pursue thank you very much
for sharing your expertise with us
Joshua talker professor Pilates and
director of the Jordan Center for the
Advanced Study of Russia long title
thank you very much good to speak to you
thanks thanks for having me